the star of the opening ceremony
now a star attraction the commonwealth
games have breathed new life into
birmingham
busy bright and bustling
[Music]
the city center is buzzing
you can't sum it up to be honest this is
something that has brought everybody
together as you can see all
everybody from all walks of life so it's
fantastic people very hyped about this
it's it's really good
great for the athletes too
england's nick miller taking gold in the
hammer throw the energy in the stadium
for this championships has just been
overwhelming um
i mean the raw the crowd is unbelievable
and it's not just the home fans but the
many visitors to the city impressed by
what they've seen
oh no it's
fair crap during um during the games
obviously there's a bit of buzz around
yeah it's it's a great atmosphere great
city to be around it's a lot more modern
than i was thinking because yeah we've
got this idea that it's really
industrial that old image of birmingham
has been replaced by pictures shown
around the world of a revitalized city i
would say the games have been huge for
birmingham
it's port birmingham on the map not only
the uk but more importantly worldwide
it's showing the city is open for
business and that business couldn't be
more welcome in a city centre that fell
quiet during covid we've really
struggled at the pandemic not really
sure and a bit uncertainty about how
things would go but it's been great to
sit here live and we've been extremely
busy from about five minutes after we
open our doors every day so it's been
great it's been fantastic organizers
promised that the games would bring
investment and improvement to birmingham
but the price was high 778
million pounds of public money was spent
delivering these games the challenge is
to make that count by building on all of
this to create a lasting legacy for the
future
but for now they're celebrating success
i mean it's been buzzing from day one
and it's just uh it brings the whole
city alive and we're all from birmingham
and we're proud of birmingham and we're
so pleased that everybody else is just
having such a phenomenal time
and the party's not over yet
becky johnson sky news birmingham